everything that Prince Harry does at the
minute attracts attention before you
even throw in a trip to Abbey Road and
welcome from John Bongiovi
the video posted on Harry's Instagram
account made it clear that publicly he
doesn't want to dwell on the serious
questions about his own future instead
he wanted the attention on the Invictus
choir
recording a new single for the military
sports event launched by Prince Harry
six years ago in the studios where the
Beatles recorded 11 of their 13 albums
just to share that moment and it's a
moment that will last I'm sure a
lifetime for a sorcerer very very
special in our past we may have heard
low esteem low self-esteem and now we
can pick ourselves up for different
reasons Jon Bon Jovi's parents were in
the US Marine Corps and he wrote to
Harry last summer offering up his song
that he'd written to raise funds ever
since they've been talking to make it
happen at the same time that Harry was
working on other plans for his family we
see it on the news
it's very different when you see
soldiers at war on the news people
change the channel and then their minds
on that when we see something like when
Harry and Megan I've gone through you
know we turn the channel often things
are over with you don't know what it's
like to walk in anyone else's shoes and
tell you they're splitting his time
between the UK and Canada has raised
questions about who's going to cover the
cost of his security but also how he's
going to keep tuned in with causes like
Invictus and why the dropping his royal
title will have an impact on the money
that they can bring in he would do it
privately so you know he will continue
to be the Duke of Sussex he'll continue
to be Prince Harry but we never used HRH
we never have you know he was never his
royal highness he was always Prince
Harry Prince Harry's Invictus games
that's all people think of it as and
none of that has changed never a great
fan of post photo opportunities this was
one that he couldn't pass up
despite the other uncertainties about
his future he won't be walking away from
his military family who always meant so
much Rianne on mills spikes
[Music]